ça y est on sait quand même une marque
qui est extrêmement connue pour avoir
que réaliser imaginer des campagnes
quand même extrêmement choc alors celle
ci c'est la dernière ça c'est le site
sur lequel vous pouvez donc trouver
celui jam unisexe de différentes
couleurs comme évidemment pour pour
benetton il est né de la collaboration
en fait entre la marque et le rapport
italien d'origine tunisienne galy en
fait lui pour lui les enfants d'immigrés
qu'il est bien il clame cette diversité
précisément et d'ailleurs il dit que la
marque n'a rencontré il n'a rencontré
aucune réticence de la marque tiff que
finalement il a donc été démarchés lui
même
elisabeth lévy nous a rejoint directrice
de la rédaction causeur alors cette
affaire de benetton qui commercialise un
hidjab unisexe ça provoque la polémique
est ce que vous en pensez est ce que
vous êtes choqués ou pas choqué par
cette affaire guillaume et moi j'en ai
marre des gens qui nous disent comment
il faut s'habiller comment il faut pas
s'habiller si les gens ont envie de
porter un hidjab ils le portent keith
haring diab unisexe ils le portent et ce
qui m'énerve le plus c'est que les
politiques qui s'offusquent de ça il
s'en fout complètement du diable ils
veulent juste faire ma récupération
politique et attiser la haine donc
franchement moi ça me choque pas du tout
vous n'avez pas débité mac leçon là non
tel ordinaire tous les mots clés ils
sont c'est à dire que pour vous le
hidjab c'est juste un morceau de tissu
bah oui bon eh bien eh ben non c'est
quoi hidjab c'est un emblème à la fois
politique culturelle et c'est un emblème
de ses parts à pied c'est pas juste un
morceau de qui tu es en quoi ça vous
dérange et bah ça me dérange parce que
je considère si vous voulez vous avez le
droit et c'est une pensée qui a tapé sa
noblesse que toutes les cultures ont le
même droit tu y étais en france et moi
je ne pense pas je pense qu'à une
culture française à rome fais comme les
romains laquelle tout le monde devrait
disons s'adapter passe au confort mais
de façon autoritaire mais s'adapter et
je vous rappelle qu'en plus le hidjab à
fleury chez nous depuis trente ans en
même temps ça il n'est pas arrivé comme
ça il est il a fleuri sous la ligne et
sciatiques des frères musulmans de
l'islamisation des quartiers il ya des
femmes en iran qui sont fouettés parce
que elles ne veulent pas le porter et il
n'est pas arrivé comme ça il arrivait
dans le cadre d'une offensive islamistes
qui nous teste et ils ont raison de nous
tester parce qu'avec des gens comme vous
et par naïveté je veux bien le croire
mais vous vous avez peur on ne s'en
sortira jamais mais bon vous trouvez que
la pause doit taper hispanisants peur de
l'islam c'est comment ça s'appelle j'ai
pas peur de l'islam en club 1 et ben
vous avez le droit du raïs le mot femme
c'est tout à fait légal d'être
islamophobe j'ai le droit de se bat j'ai
le droit de ne pas aimer l'islamisation
de notre pays
d'accord ensuite en l'occurrence il ya
autre chose dans cette campagne parce
que casquette de quoi s'agit-il on nous
on essaye de nous marier deux choses
inconciliables c'est-à-dire un symbole
de la différenciation sexuelle et même
de l'intériorité d'un sexe avec un
symbole de l'indifférenciation donc
c'est complètement c'est évidemment si
vous voulez c'est une blague absurde
aucun homme musulman j'ai dit on ne va
sur le versement ne valent portée s'ils
voulaient que je suis sûr que non mais
en fait c'est toujours la même offensive
il s'agit de nous acclimater qui veut
nous dire c'est la diarrhée le palladia
trikini après le burkini sur ce sera les
minarets fenêtres et les minarets des
données dans la diatribe classique de
madame lévy contre l'islam moi je suis
pour le port du voile qui est tout à
fait très bien et votre ailleurs
d'ailleurs il est autorisé en france et
c'est légal madame lévis le port du
voile est là donc vous éthique les
matchs que les gars là et là je critique
les marques mais là je trouve que
l'initiative est formidable la méthode
que ces initiatives inclusive c'est à
dire que le voilier se voit là je
rappelle qui est légal et qui ne couvre
pas le visage il est pour tout le monde
c'est le même et je trouve ça bien au
moment où déjà vous avez vous trouvé la
mire des jeunes femmes musulmanes sont
stigmatisés alors que moi je les
rencontre contrairement à vous et
qu'elle me dise qu'elle est le voile est
bien là je trouve que c'est un signe
d'ouverture à bord qui étaient tous ces
3 [ __ ] tombe d'abord vous ne savez rien de
qui je rends compte et qu'ils
rencontrent pas ça met en oeuvre en
bonne ça vous soyez et tourner ça vous
fera le plus grand bien l'étonnement est
une sainte rose
contrairement à ce que tu dis moi je
prends un simple simplement que c'est du
buzz à bombay bien sûr ils se sont fait
peur ils se sont simplement dit rizhao
c'est un mot clé qui va évidemment faire
parler benetton qu'est ce qu'ils font
depuis des heures ils font des
polémiques souvenez-vous le curé
qu'embrasser une note souvenez-vous
l'anorexie qui était au bord de la porte
de la mort malheureusement qui est
décédé quelques temps après et c'est
donc là ils se sont dit qu'ils allaient
tous maîtrisent pas la société s'élève à
prendre déjà pas que c'est en comptant
la veille cagoule mixte et ben il y
aurait pas de problème alors on met donc
même son siècle jeanne n'est pas juste à
m'en soucier des bourses si vous mettez
wind on sait que ces cadets la question
ne s'est pas trop osé
également question georget paquet la
xoom et nous jamais vous la polémique
qui va s'y mettre mais pas les questions
il
répondra pour moi c'est juste c'est
juste un coup de pub ça et là on est en
train d'y participer bien sûr mais ça
c'est vrai on aimerait vous répondre
parce que en réalité vous tapez raison
ils veulent se faire un coup de pub et
je devais sierra leone nous y
contribuons mais derrière ça vous savez
très bien que ces boîtes veulent se
donner une image inclusive comme a dit
gilles verdez qui est d'ailleurs trop de
sa mère bio derrière ya l'idée de nous
dire mais finalement vous voyez bien le
hidjab c'est sympa c'est moderne c'est
inclusif c'est rigolo c'est transgressif
c'est tout ce que vous voulez et bien
moi je vous dis que ça fait 30 ans s'ils
voulaient qu'on se fait avoir derrière
les campagnes de pub de benetton par des
offensives autrement plus dangereux
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on en est
là je ne dis pas que cette campagne là
en soi c'est dramatique si vous voulez
je pense qu'elle est absurde on peut je
vous dis ah le lp s'entrechoquer des
choses anodines sauf que c'est galli ce
rappeur italien qui est très très connue
en italie qu'à 2 3 millions de followers
alors il va chercher benetton et qui va
leur dire moi je veux faire ça d'accord
benetton qui va voir galli oui bon bon
alors qu'elle by humans bene tour demain
galy lui d'origine tunisienne était à
l'eau tu nies siens il n'est pas à la
base italien est italien parce qu'il ya
deux ans en italie contrairement à l'as
d'accord et donc et donc et non et donc
en fait être que vous pensez pas que
justement c'est tout le contraire qui
fait en voulant un niqab unisexe
d'ailleurs
giscardien anitea mini sec alors que la
moyenne il porte sur ces réseaux ils
portent en couverture d'un magazine gens
vont penser beaucoup que vous pensez
vraiment dit quand réformer l'islam et
que demain si vous voulez des musulmans
vont en masse homme portait le hidjab
pour dire finalement vous voyez bien le
hidjab dans les flammes mérité pour
faire à l'idée sur quoi pour ces faits
pour faire une distinction parce que la
femme ne doit pas être un objet de désir
et de concupiscence je te donne à quoi
il ya que des hommes il est de porter
son patrimoine dans la campagne ce sont
que des nations c'est une campagne de
pub c'est précisément alors est bel et
bien remplie avec s'essouffler on est où
là eric zemmour chariot le walkie smpt
au service de l'islamisation du monde
occidental
qui fait référence aux termes aucun bien
sûr que signifie être réveillé en
anglais to book ah oui
c'est vraiment la rencontre c'est
l'internationalité des buts si vous
l'êtes dans un dans un leurre guy si on
y
joue dit assia nous on fait ce qu'on
veut c'est beaucoup plus ces dernières
le hidjab aurore bergé
qu'elle peut toujours réagir à tous les
présidents de délégués des députés elle
la république aux marches le hidjab a
choisi fou la folie identitaire on pense
d'abord une fête nous tellement cela
semble délirant mais c'est bien en vente
la vente âge on ne peut pas l'acheter et
ne plus se rendre chez benetton voilà
alors donc mais on a aussi le droit de
penser que c'est putassier commercial
j'aime pas les campagnes de pub de
benetton celle-ci incluse d'accord ça va
pas je vais pas chercher au delà mais
moi j'aime pas du tout du tout du tout
j'ai les 80 fr et ni jabbes respirant
ils l'ont retirée de ça m'énerve que à
chaque fois que vous énerve au sommet le
moules-frites qu'on parle de sa mort on
peut voir ça comme une démarche
effectivement d'un rappeur d'un créateur
on peut voir ça comme un une démarche
inclusive on peut voir ça comme des
signaux positifs et madame levitte
toujours vous casser ça vous fracassez
année mais vous devriez vous ouvrir un
peu ouvrir il réduit un peu et vous avez
de déverser parisienne région
dormir dans vos propos soyez gentil
aller prier un document soyez gentil
aller prêcher quelqu'un me collard moi
je suis un cas désespéré vous verrez ce
que vous aimez les territoires perdus et
fait rire du tout benetton a voulu faire
un coup dans lequel vous êtes tous
tombés mais je vais vous dire c'est
uniquement un coup de com pour la marque
benetton y avait ma maman à 1019
décathlon avait fait une cagoule qui
avait eu nicolas qui avait été repris à
l'époque il avait tenté de l'arrêter
alors que c'était une cagoule pour le
running mais il faut arrêter de voir
l'islam partout là en l'occurrence et
cagoules c'est un homme regardez un peu
le sujet les appels quand ça passe dit
j'avoue ça s'appelle cagoule on est
plutôt sur une cagoule la non en bon et
bien moi je vous dis que si ça s'appelle
hidjab c'est pour nous vendre quelque
chose au-delà d'un morceau de tissu je
le répète alors vous avez le droit
d'aimer l'islamisation
couture et trouvé que ces territoires
perdus et rigueur qui
sont des anciens merveilleux je le sais
vous le dit à chaque fois